Researchers at the University of Bradford
are developing a simple universal blood test
to diagnose cancer.
And a baseball team in Korea now allows fans
to cheer through a computer and have it physically
represented at the stadium by a robot.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
Jibo is the first robot that will be a part
of your family.
Designed by famed roboticist Cynthia Breazeal,
Jibo is an interactive companion and helper.
It comes with several apps including one that
takes pictures using a facial tracker, a personal
assistant that keeps your schedule and provides
reminders, a telepresence app for long distance
communication and even a storyteller that
uses sound effects and graphics to entertain
kids.
The crowdfunding campaign aims to create a
community of developers using Jibo as a platform
in order to maximize the potential of the
social robot planning to roll out in 2015.
One of the longest pieces of dinosaur coprolite
recently sold at auction for $8,500.
Coprolite is fossilized poop.
In related news, newly discovered tracks add
to the theory that T-Rexes hunted in packs.
Which is terrifying.
The world’s largest laser is helping researchers
study planet formation by crushing diamonds.
The 30 foot long laser along with 175 other
lasers combine to exert 50 million times the
amount of Earth’s atmospheric pressure on
a single diamond and they're doing this to
learn what the core of huge planets like Saturn
might look like.
Sense is a bedside monitor and smart alarm
that kind of turns sleeping into a video game.
It uses a sensor clipped onto a pillow to
monitor the bedroom environment and how well
you slept and gives you a score - so if the
room is pitch black you gain points but if
a car alarm woke you up at 3 am - you lose
points.
With the smart alarm function if you’re
supposed to be up at 9:30 but you’re awake
at 9:15 - it’ll go off early so you don’t
fall back to sleep.
Waking you up at the optimum time.
The recently unveiled Mercedes Benz Future
Truck 2025 drives itself.
It’s equipped the Highway Pilot assistance
system that drives completely autonomously
up to 85 km/h.
The prototype was tested on a stretch of the
Autobahn near East Germany and responded perfectly
to traffic but it retains a steering wheel
for critical maneuvers.
And they hope to have them on the road by
2025.
Largest aquatic insect recently found in China
with a 21 cm wingspan.
That’s 8.2 inches.
A new study shows that fist-pumping transmit
significantly fewer bacteria than shaking
hands.
And nearly twice as many bacteria are transmitted
during a handshake compared to a high-five.
Researchers say the fist bump could substantially
reduce the transmission of infectious diseases
between people.
Finding Rover is an app that uses facial recognition
to help find lost dogs.
Users take a front-facing photo of their dog
and if someday it gets lost the app scans
all the missing dogs in the area.
Conversely you can help return lost dogs by
snapping a photo and matching the face and
getting the owner’s contact info.
Researchers at Carnegie Melon have created
a camera-filled dome that recreates full 3-D
motion scenes.
The two-story geodesic dome features over
500 cameras capturing 100,000 different points
in motion at any time without the need for
physical markers.
This could be a huge upgrade to motion capture
for movies and video games and even eventually
be used in sporting events and concerts by
taking advantage of the crowd’s cell phone
cameras.
Finally, Center Of The Sun is synced with
glitch animation representing the life cycle
of an Olmec sun god.
I’m gonna leave you with a Macgyver robot
that uses environmental objects as tools - and
as always thanks for watching!